I want to make sure I ask you about
Prince what was that story where you
were helping him out he had an all-girl
group and he you were helping him out
with it and you would never met him
you'd only talk to him on the phone Etc
but then you somehow ended up
at his place Paisley Park and you got to
see him do purple rain and you said you
were reduced to tears how'd that all
come about so I was in a girl group as
well girl party like my DJ Sophia Ayers
was in it as well and there was like
this documentary about local artists and
a third eye girl is Princess group and
we were all coming up at the same time
and then the radio station they're the
current I guess he
emailed them and they called us and was
like
um Prince is looking for you and we were
like wait what and so that was kind of
how it all happened it was like come to
Paisley Park and
um get on this song Third Eye girl song
boy trouble I think it was like Easter
Sunday too
everything about him
who's this song you're wrong
yeah I mean it paid off like he loved it
and put it on the album and
um paid us in increments of seven and
um I bought my first laptop and uh after
that it was just like every time he
wanted us to perform at Paisley Park we
you know went out and performed so we
put what would go on there in other
words it's a private thing at Paisley
Park right Paisley Parks his home so
it's not like you're playing for the
public you're playing for Prince and
like what is friends it's more than a
home it is kind of like a Music Factory
type place you know and it had this like
Holiness to it too his freaking
motorcycle from Purple Rain just sitting
on display and like sometimes he would
just like sit on it just like to [ __ ]
with people and like Finding Nemo
playing like on the projected on the
wall and like a giant print symbol just
like illuminated on the wall like it was
it was more and like his home was
obviously like you know upstairs and
stuff but like it was like whoa this
person lives here you can't tell like
you don't know where you are why would
Prince at his at this place have Finding
Nemo up on a like like it was his
favorite movie and
um I do cherish those memories a lot and
um
yeah seeing him perform on a piano and
just like singing was like it was the
last time I saw him and it was beautiful
I cried
he cried I remember when he passed I
like tweeted this too I said I'm going
to commit to positive music I'm
dedicated to positive music and if you
think I'm too happy because that was a
that was a criticism I got a lot they
were like you're too happy like that's
corny I'm like if you think I'm too
happy there's check yourself
check it you're okay because I'm gonna
spread love and positivity and that's
what Prince really wanted
so I um there you go I'm still doing it
to this day baby nothing but love and
Good Vibes over here how great you got
to be friendly with Prince you know and
you had a moment with him you were
crying with him I still don't even
believe it
oh